I know that I am not particularly
predisposed towards metaphysical
questions because I don't think they can
really be answered so the idea of what
started the universe we can't really
answer that I think that to say god
that's just a placeholder for ignorance
right that doesn't help you know here
with Prager regress ya know so where did
God come from it just it's just putting
off that moment of ignorance a little
bit further hey I'm Dave Rubin and
unless I've been impeached by a
completely partisan vote this is still
the Rubin report as always a quick
reminder to click the subscribe bell so
you guys have a small chance of seeing
our videos right here on the YouTube and
more importantly joining me today is an
author political commentator and fellow
at the Manhattan Institute Heather
McDonald welcome back to the river
it's such an honor Dave thank you so
much for having me on I'm glad to have
you back had you on about a year ago and
the people they love you that's what I
learned that's what I learned in the
youtube comment section it's just they
are up being in your presence you know
it's there's so much love coming at you
that a little spills over well you're
killing it in the scarf game today so I
feel like I have to be very sharp thank
you brilliant
so here we go so one of the things I
wanted to start with here is something
that we discussed briefly about five or
ten minutes in our last year's view you
are a secular conservative and I think a
lot of conservatives seem to think that
that is either an oxymoron or just
simply cannot exist because conservatism
has to have some sort of religious
underpinning so I thought that would
just be an interesting place for us to
pick up the conversation I base my
conservatism on on empirical truth on
what I've observed in life I can talk
about the necessity of the two-parent
family because we can see empirically
what happens when the marriage norm
breaks down in communities I most
traditional values because I think we
have a history of of stability when
those are honored I don't think it's
particularly stable to rest a set of
political principles or more
principles on the basis of revealed
wisdom that this holy book supports this
and I've I'll notice this people who I
respect enormous Lee Dave whether it's
dennis prager or michael medved that are
making the argument that you cannot have
a moral society without a foundation of
religious belief i would ask them these
are two brilliant Jewish thinkers why
don't you believe that Jesus is the Son
of God it's revealed truth the New
Testament says that this is gospel they
don't base achill II if you're going
that far with religion and you're saying
you need this revealed truth this belief
to organize a society why not the next
level of the revealed truth or whatever
the next level is or something like that
right they will not take it as simply
necessary truth the fact that the New
Testament claims to be the Word of God
why don't they believe that they're
basing their same belief in the Old
Testament on the same claim that the New
Testament makes they just choose to be
agnostic or atheistic about one of those
holy books I could apply the same
challenge to their belief that the Old
Testament is the revealed truth because
it's simply self self validating so I
would look for a different set of
principles that are does not depend on
one's suspension of disbelief and an
acceptance that something is revealed
truth for my moral code so with that
being said does it matter to you if the
end result is the same right so I'm
gonna guess that on most of the
important issues of the day you probably
agree in large part with both Dennis and
Michael Medved right and most
conservative thinkers that maybe come
from a more religious background so at
the end of the day when it all washes
away do do you think it really matters
do you think that's sort of a long-term
problem I know I guess if we arrived at
the same place I think it's it it's a
problem for that segment of voters or
thinkers who don't find those appeals
particularly
interesting but I have to I'll be very
honest Dave part of my resistance to
this is simply I don't find claims of
petitionary prayer and the idea of a
personal loving God consistent with what
I see what I call the daily massacre of
the innocence to me it's a very hard
claim to make that I should expect God
to pay attention to my well-being when
he's willing to allow horrific things to
happen to people far more deserving and
innocent that I am so for me it's partly
just a truth value I cannot stomach what
appears to me to be a patently false
claim about a personal loving God it's
interesting I've mentioned that I've had
John Kasich in here who's the former
governor of Ohio and presidential
candidacy and when I asked him about
faith he said something that I that
sounded sort of almost flippant but I
thought it was really actually pretty
insightful he said you know some people
can do it with God I just can't and I
thought that was actually like you know
for a certain set of people they where
you're able to sort of always sort of
maybe go back to your intellectual side
some people just sort of get tired of
that does that well I and I also think
it's a very I think its genetic I know
that I am not particularly predisposed
towards metaphysical questions because I
don't think they can really be answered
so the idea of what started the universe
we can't really answer that I think that
to say god that's just a placeholder for
ignorance right that doesn't help you
know cause here with Prager regress you
know so where did God come from it just
it's just putting off that moment of
ignorance a little bit further so I
don't find those questions particularly
relevant on the other hand I recognize
that for much of humanity that is a very
deep need to ask these basic questions
about origin and an end point where we
all headed what is the meaning of life
to me anybody who claims that they don't
he doesn't find meaning in life when
there is Mozart and Hyden to
dennis prager favorite or Beethoven or
John Milton or Aeschylus or Anthony
Trollope or just whatever you do doing
trying to do the best you can do I don't
find life meaningless for one second
yeah so does it worry you then when
Republicans or more broadly
conservatives talk about God all the
time or now that we're seeing sort of a
huge fracture and what's happening with
the left they're like completely afraid
to even mention God or anything like
that Bernie I think is basically an
atheist although he won't really say it
because I think there would be political
repercussions but are you like does that
make you sort of feel not totally at
home with the Conservatives well you
know I I grew up in a very secular
environment and so it was a novel
discovery to me in the 90s when I was in
a more conservative writing circle and I
grew up as a default liberal I hadn't
been exposed to religion I mean it is an
amazing thing I had been educated on the
coasts and I didn't realize how
different they were so in one sense I'm
very parochial and I hadn't been exposed
to the degree of religious faith I guess
I find it I'm always amazed what to me
seems parochialism when I hear it's
essentially Christians in a political
environment getting up there and talking
about Jesus as God my view immediately
is well there are Jews around you know
at the villas and there are Muslims yeah
how can you be so confident that
everybody in this audience is of that
particular faith and I also would notice
simply that religion has been tamed by
the Enlightenment
it has now been taught to mind its
manners and sit quietly in the corner
mm-hmm we all you know the the great
kissing wissy between Jews and
Christians that we all now talk about
the judeo-christian environment I Harris
Heritage and perhaps rightly so that's a
novel thing right it wasn't like that it
everything's called the Crusades exactly
and all these religious supporters are
saying we cannot live without it
they are conveniently overlooking what
the history of religion has been in our
tradition and still is in many other
places that have not gone through the
Enlightenment the concept of tolerance
is not a religious concept it's an
Enlightenment concept and religion in in
the West has been forced to accept
tolerance which is a very good thing but
that is not an idea that is inherent to
religion right so I don't want to be
Prager or medvetz no don't lawyer at the
moment but I think what they would say
is that it was the it was all the
religious stuff that organized society
that allowed us to get to the
Enlightenment so that the Enlightenment
could then you know unfurl all these
good ideas well I don't think I don't
think Christianity or judeo-christianity
has any necessary monopoly on moral
virtues I think there's a certain core
sense of I don't know any culture that
says murder is okay but every culture
starts to know certain distinctions what
they don't last that long right yeah
it's fun for a moment you know you get
to give in to your your most aggressive
tendencies right where do you think
Trump falls out on this because I don't
think anyone really thinks he's a
religious person or perhaps even a
believer in any real sense of it yet
Christians or evangelicals especially
really seem to like the job that he's
doing well I don't think he has
particular principles or deep thoughts
about much of anything I think he will
he's a chameleon he takes on the
coloring of what is convenient at the
time so whether he believes or not I I
don't know he I don't think he's thought
much deeply about it either and it
doesn't really matter but certainly he's
willing to speak that rhetoric in order
to get get that vote if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlists all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell